we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p we've been
talking about the elizabeth warren a
Native American PR Fiasco I talked about
it on last Friday's show spoke about it
today a little bit with Bill share when
thinking about electability for the
Democratic primary for 2020 here's a
voicemail about this situation which
takes a little bit of a different point
of view take a listen David you are miss
reading this I'm Elizabeth Warren
situation what she needs to do is just
come out and say like yeah I cleaned
myself as Native American because I
would have gotten special privileges or
advantages because due to my Native
American status and like after she does
that I mean like everyone won't
understand that right you know the
problem with that is that I don't
believe she believed she would get
advantages by listing herself as Native
American so with the Texas State Bar
where she listed herself as American
Indian that was something that is just
for statistical purposes it wouldn't
conviction vay any benefits whatsoever
or privileges with you Penn and Harvard
everything that we know is that this is
how she was listed after decisions had
already been made about whether she was
going to be able to be at those places
so I think that as I said last week this
has turned into a PR problem but I don't
have any particular reason to think that
Elizabeth Warren number one knew that
she had so little Native American
ancestry and number two that she
believed that she was going to get
benefits conferred to her tell me if I'm
wrong Pat but we've seen no evidence
that it would even be reasonable to
think that there would be privileges
associated with that because she was
listing this listing herself this way
for statistical purposes yeah I mean
certainly not from what we initially
knew about this whole controversy maybe
with the stuff that came out recently
about the Bar Association application
you can make a case there I think that
this is just going to
stick to her until Election Day if she
makes it this far that far yeah I don't
think it's very good for her it's not
good for her electability and we'll see
what the consequences are yeah I don't
think it's going away unfortunately even
though I mean listen you've got a
president who's a serial liar is
involved in rampant criminality in all
aspects of his life is is the problem
that you're going to choose him over
Elizabeth Warren because she miss stated
her Native American heritage it's it's
absolutely laughable
but as far as the voicemail is concerned
I don't think Elizabeth Warren should
admit that she was trying to gain an
advantage by listing herself as Native
American because I've not seen any
evidence that that's actually what she
believed and what she was trying to do
on today's bonus show we will talk in
more detail about the guilty verdict
against El Chapo from the El Chapo trial
we're also going to talk about a real
problem to our biosphere which is the
plummeting insect population and we will
also get an update on Sweden's cashless
experiment which we've talked about
before how is it going and are there any
problems that have surfaced all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
make sure you get access to the bonus
show by either becoming a member at WWE
pakman.com or by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show it's
a great bonus show for you today and I
would love to have your support and
speak to you then